[Music]
I'm the big screen to screen up in TV
I'm kicking it off on May 21st the one
the only Twin Peaks grab some cherry pie
get a damn fine cup of coffee because we
are going back to the beyond strange
town of Twin Peaks it's a reboot that's
coming up on Showtime it has been 25
years since this short-lived show was on
ABC it only lasted two seasons and it
has such a culture behind it so many
fans love it so I'm really excited to
see what Showtime is going to do with it
especially being in that premium cable
format so I can go I can go back and
watch the original pretty quickly very
quickly it's only two seasons do you
need to watch the original to start up
with this one I would okay I would check
you can appreciate it exactly you know
where we can watch the original uh well
I do know that you can buy it on Amazon
Prime okay that is what I did uh and I
think that Showtime has acquired the
rights and you can also read watch it
through the show time now that makes
sense oh there you go yes uh and of
course I've been waiting to say this for
such a long time Game of Thrones is back
season seven okay hey finally you guys
alright so here's what's going on it
premieres on July 16th on HBO and by
that time it will have been 395 days
since we were last in Westeros at whose
count
I was not counting or checking things
off on my office cubicle but the
interesting thing about this season is
that they're splitting up season seven
into two seasons over the course of two
years so rather than getting ten of
episodes Rome getting seven this time
around and then also because it's
premiering so late in the summer it's
not eligible for this year's Emmys
whereas last year it swept the Emmys to
come twelve so it's gonna be interesting
to see what a year without Game of
Thrones at the Emmys is gonna be oh yeah
yeah I had one of those in a while in a
really long time so I think all those
other dramas like this is our year can
we go for one second about these
spin-offs that they're developing more
game of throwing offs for them it is
insane and honestly my my TV loving
heart is gonna burst right now it's
almost a little much for me right I mean
I don't know but I just don't want no
way they can't green like that many
there I would say that they're gonna
probably do too okay so but they think
they're just covering all of their
Westeros spaces at this point moving
from premium cable to the other TV big
header Netflix where everyone is
streaming everything and the thing
everyone is most excited is the
defenders he's been a long time coming
because we've had to go through so many
other seasons of setting up the origin
stories of daredevil Jessica Jones Luke
Cage and iron fist and now for the first
time they are all assembling together
together allowed the Avengers and going
to fight crime in New York we still
don't know much about what the big bad
is the season but Sigourney Weaver I
mean yeah little bit we don't know much
about who she's playing but we do know
that she is done done done very evil
woman in the trailer I was just like oh
yeah exactly
exactly and then of course we have
seasons five of both house of cards and
orange is the new black and the
interesting thing about orange is the
new black is that when we last left off
it was a huge cliffhanger of poussey
dying and now we know that all 10
episodes of orange is the new black
season 5 is going to take place over
just three days Wow so it's going to be
very heightened a lot of emotions a lot
of crying I'm a predicting so get your
tears out for that and your tissues as
well oh yeah it's your tear the dollars
are common the tears are coming then of
course we have reality TV which is what
TV is kind of known for in the
summertime we've got Big Brother coming
back so you think you didn't dance and
then a newcomer to the reality world
world of dance which is on NBC it's got
a lot of big names attached to it's got
Jennifer Lopez Derek Hough Jenna Dewan
Tatum and neo were they all right one of
these days I think that j.lo girl's
gonna make it she's really gonna be a
big thing
exactly I don't know how she has time to
do anything I really don't know either
but this what's really cool about this
competition is that anybody can compete
in it it's not just pairs it's not just
groups it's kind of be kind of the world
of dance very so it's going to be good
to see how that does there's a lot of
buzz behind it right now and a lot of
buzz in the row man
to front this year because my favorite
summer show for TV unreal is coming back
for a third season it is so good and
this is the first time that we're going
to see a suit rests on everlasting so
which means that they're going to be so
many suitors going after her heart which
means so many shirtless man ha ha ha ha
look at how much more awesome how much
more bonkers that show can get oh it can
get very bothered I was actually on set
for season 3 and I can't play any clips
for mix it's all heavily under embargo
but it is going to be so good and it's a
perfect time because we of course have
the Bachelorette coming this year which
is with another big first we have Rachel
Lindsay the first african-american
Bachelorette looking oh so gorgeous in
the first promo shot um and honestly she
just seems like a sweetheart so I'm
excited to see what she's got
[Music]
you
[Music]